il captait ton téléphone
non j'ai plus de réseau bonjour madame
vous reliez largement au dessus de la
limite de vitesse
monsieur monsieur vous m'entendez
marchal james dillon je présume moi
c'est diablo cette ville est à moi
alors c'est dans ce trou vous avez
atterri après avoir buté votre
coéquipier pour ça qu'ils peuvent plus
de flingues vous n'avez pas intérêt à
blesser qui que ce soit est ce que je me
suis fait comprendre qu est ce que tu
veux ou la chambre en forme car rien
d'autre à voler ici y aurait de quoi
dans 28 minutes si un fourgon blindé au
moindre souci prévient dont la police
d'état ça c'est ce qu'on verra
je vais vous envoyer au trot il va
falloir me buter
si tu as besoin je vois tu as pensé à
tout
balance taux plein quote moi